yeah I'm gonna be dealing with heavy
spoilers really quickly so yeah that's
going up front phase space Westworld
Season 2 episode 6 so yeah
Ford's back kind of sort of maybe it's
weird that honestly genuinely surprised
me and then surprised me again with the
fact that it surprised me like I feel
like I should have seen that coming like
that should not have been a surprise at
all but I don't know something about the
way everything else has been shot the
fact that he hadn't even appeared in
flashbacks you know up to that point to
me just really said that oh okay they
didn't want to pay for Anthony Hopkins
to do anything this season we will never
see him again so I think possibly for
that more meta reason I honestly thought
he was not gonna be coming back so just
seeing that oh that was a good that was
a good end point on this episode but I
don't want to do all that too much but I
do want to say that it didn't need that
kind of punch this is a good episode but
it's coming off the back of two really
amazingly good episodes that [ __ ] that
really drilled in and focused on some
specific characters who are it's some of
the most interesting and really move
their stories forward this this is an
episode that's a bit more connective
tissue it's a little bit more taking the
characters from where they were left
from the last couple of episodes in
getting them to wherever they need to be
for the next thing that's gonna happen
so it's a transition episode I don't
want to call it filler it does serve
plot functions but it it's more about
getting the everybody arranged in the
position they need to be in rather than
being the other big o moments so and
those sorts of things are often
necessary and these shows and it's a
pretty good example
of something like that and also it helps
because oftentimes after a couple of
really couple of really stellar episodes
you sometimes just get a nosedive and
this isn't that it's just it's just this
shift to something else so yeah works
pretty well as far as specific stories
go I really enjoyed the man in black and
his daughter I liked seeing him get
dressed down a bit and she is definitely
the character to do that that was a
really interesting dynamic to play and
then of course being such a unrepentant
bastard that he is he doesn't stick
around that he bails on her he he really
is a an atrocious human being I loved
watching him I loved how the episode
opens with Dolores and there's something
about her with him became ago why would
you ever be afraid of me and not at all
that's so good
and the stuff Coyle with Bernard is
weird so like I already mentioned
forward but like so Bernard is kind of
in the host personality storage unit
which is also the park or it's
structured to be like the part add to
the mind of whatever host has been put
in there that's interesting that's odd I
wouldn't have called that but at the
same time I can think of logical reasons
why that would be the case if even
during periods of of maintenance or or
you know just being stored if the best
way to keep everything active and
working as well as it should be is to
keep it engaged well the best thing to
do is to just have it cycling through
the same things it would be doing if it
was still in physical form and not just
in a you know I uploaded persona to the
cloud sort of thing so that that does
track when I think about it and but it
was it in the moment watching I was like
what the
hell but like in a good way like in an
intrigue way um Maeve was great I knew I
mean I knew from before she well not
before but before this season this when
she first said she was gonna find her
daughter I remember thinking that kid is
not gonna remember you that there's no
way they would have left her with that
because I mean you didn't remember until
you became self-aware so I knew that
that kid was not gonna recognize her and
they hammered that home and they
hammered that home hard I am really
curious as told what is going on with
the ghost nation it really seems like
there's something going on under the
surface as to why they're behaving the
way they are and I really want to get
some answers on that and fairly soon I
mean the corporate espionage stuff
Tessa Thompson's whole thing and she's
still good in the park but her storyline
is still the least interesting although
still not awful because the show has
been really smart about not letting
letting that ever become the dominant
story in any of these episodes that I
think it's a very good call
try think oh I was really kind of
saddened seeing how ruthless Teddy was
now and also kind of seen Dolores his
face because I think it's only now
really occurring to her what it is that
she did and what it is she lost what she
took away from herself by changing Teddy
the way that she did I think the the
weight of him not being the same
inherently good guy that she always had
at her side is going to start to weigh
on her or at least I hope so it's it's
it's hinted really really nicely in this
episode before Maeve has her whole thing
with the with the kid we get a little
bit more of her and show gonna world I
really enjoyed that it's a beautiful
setting I love a bamboo forest so that
was great stuff those performers really
are
I'm glad it makes sense that not all of
them are gonna go with her but I am glad
that they kept you know for I forgive
that I'm not saying it to be flippant
flippant I'm saying because it's
literally true they kept the girl with
the Dragon Tattoo and I like that I like
Mae building her little core group of
murder friends it's it's good it's nice
it's good to make friends especially if
they'll murder people with you and her
iLike the sort of the implementation of
a certain guiding philosophy in terms of
her use of her ability to basically just
tell hosts to do whatever she wants them
to do and this idea of not taking away
someone's fate because she could make
anybody do anything that they want but
if she has a few guiding principles and
you know she she may stick to them she
may break them we'll see but as long as
there's something like that that that is
a form of restriction on what she can do
because they've established that she has
if not hard rules at the very least
guidelines for herself that becomes an
answer for why didn't she just do that
thing she knows how to do and just cause
that you know use that to to fix the
problem and sometimes she does but I
think I'm gaining enough understanding
about her headspace in terms of when she
uses that to be okay with the times she
chooses not to and I think you know
plothole wise house that was those a
good thing to kind of establish I think
that plays out well I think that's
pretty much it there's nothing there's
nothing bad in this episode there's no
false steps yeah in this episode but
it's highs are not as high as the last
couple episodes but it's so really good
and I am dang curious and dang invested
to see the next episode but have you
seen Westworld episode 6 what did you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down the comments
let's talk about it there's all the
stuff to do so just like subscribe and
support me on patreon follow me on
Twitter and even more than
that links to all these things that I
just mentioned and the things that I
didn't are all done in the description
so until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]